ils veulent parfaitement en ligne un
vrai ballet flottant compétition
régionale de cerfs-volants ce dimanche
qualificative pour les championnats de
france en 2013
depuis le parc des quatre saisons à
plaisir plusieurs manches disputées en
individuel en perd ou par équipe chaque
fois la même règle réalisé trois figures
imposées
des figures choisi chaque début d'année
par les instances internationales est
évalué sur le terrain par des juges
les figures on les connaît par coeur à
nous d'y réaliser le mieux possible dans
une échelle il est né chez elle par la
première fenêtre devant et il faut le
faire comme il faut et après le ballet
ça va entre deux et quatre minutes se
ravaler musicale je dirais ça s'approche
un peu de paternité sic par exemple le
jugeant leur art une boucle il regarde
si la figure et l'exécuter si les angles
sont bien faits si la vitesse est
toujours la même et sur respectable
après rychel
leurs noms de clubs de plaisir et
l'organisateur de la manifestation un
club bien armée qui compte des adhérents
placé entre les 5e et les 10e place au
niveau national ainsi qu'une équipe
vice-championne d'europe
à les voir évoluer dans le ciel bleu
plaisir wa tout paraît si simple si on
sait faire du vélo ce faire le
cerf-volant c'est le même principe vous
imagine examen guidon dans les mains
pour aller à gauche en vélo on va
pousser à gauche à droite tueur a tiré à
gauche pousse à droite et inversement
pour la droite
le cerf-volant c'est pareil il suffit
juste de savoir sa pâle avoir peur
prendre son temps rester calmes mais
c'est vincent bayard est un compétiteur
mais également un initiateur il donne
des cours en une après-midi de pratique
il est possible selon lui de savoir
faire décoller son cerf-volant et de
démarrer des évolutions mais pour une
maîtrise totale
il faudra tout de même compter plusieurs
heures d'entraînement